it has been hasn't it the big problem in
the early days of his administration
with that emergency statement the House
of Commons by the Home Secretary
explaining both why she had leaked or
sent sorry documents via her personal
email half a dozen time breaching
ministerial code she had to go and
explain that and then obviously this
developing and worrying situation in
manston in that detent one not just had
that processing center where it has
appeared that thousands of people have
been kept there for more than 24 hours
uh breaking legal duties by the
government and the role of the Home
Secretary in processing or not
processing people now immigration is
typically an area where labor have not
felt strong on
um not least because of their position
on brexit
and immigration controls it's
traditionally been quite a strong
position for the conservatives but not
today you what you saw there was a prime
minister being absolutely hammered on
immigration policy Kirsten are really
going uh for Rishi sunak on matters of
immigration he criticized him over the
processing of claims
um at that point there was an admission
from Rishi sunak that there hasn't been
enough processing of claims he said not
enough claims have been processed of
people coming over in small boats you
know there's record numbers this year 40
000 people already and it's not even at
the end of the year uh the prime
minister's saying it's not enough and we
are going to fix that and kill storm are
coming back with that repost there
saying he can say that again four
percent of those who arrived in small
boats uh their claims have been
processed in the past year he then asked
just on this very tricky question for
swella bravaman on whether she did or
did not ignore legal advice given to her
about the need to find accommodation for
migrants that were staying in that
Center that should have been processed
and put into other accommodation we
found out that they haven't that they
people have been staying there for weeks
in overcrowded conditions with outbreaks
of diseases reports today about people
trying to Fashion weapons and and all
sorts of potential unrest that we picked
up
and has been reported on Sky News uh
kirstama asking directly whether or not
the Home Secretary ignored legal advice
yes or no the Prime Minister duck in
that question saying you know government
policies that we don't comment on legal
advice Kia storm is saying I think
that's because the answer is yes and I
have to say Jane I have two sources both
telling me home office sources
that that advice
was ignored or maybe it was rejected but
it wasn't accepted now I have to say the
Home Secretary on record in the House of
Commons and said I did not ignore legal
advice but the point of all of this is
that labor have clearly taken decision
that this is a running problem this is
an open wound for Rishi sunak in terms
of the early days of his Premiership and
they're really hammering at home and for
Rishi sunak I think he gave quite a kind
of Spirited performance though I mean he
does manage to project confidence at the
dispatch box but in terms of the
questions around policy that was really
uncomfortable for him and it is hard for
him isn't it you know the labor party
are able to say you've been in power for
12 years your own home secretary is
admitted that the Asylum system is
broken whose fault is it and and rishi's
coming back you know as you say
kierstama pushing you know you've got to
crack down on gangs you've got to speed
up Asylum claims Richardson X responds
to that one was well let me take you
back to things you've said and and
bringing up Jeremy corbyn there'll be
some who will say you can't deflect I
mean questions of that nature I mean the
two the two defense lines that Rishi
sunak had there was you didn't vote for
legislation that we think would have
tightened border controls uh of course
because of everything that's going on
and the admission by the Home Secretary
that the system is broken uh that is not
a particularly effective defense for a
prime minister but it's all he's got in
that moment
um in terms of the Corbin attack line
what's happening in terms of of
political attack lines between these two
men now is that kirstarma
is bringing up this issue of The Grubby
dealers he puts it between Rishi sunak
and swella bravman the position that the
leader of the opposition is trying to
make is that you put the uh you
reappointed a Home Secretary for
political reasons when there were
reasons around conduct and reasons about
competence that that person shouldn't
have been put back in the pace so this
is The Grubby deal now
response to that as you said Jane is to
say well you're the guy that said Jeremy
corbyn was going to be a great prime
minister and I'm going to keep reminding
you of that now you could argue that
because
um Jeremy corbyn's not even a member of
the labor but I mean he's been he's lost
the whip
um that that is a blunt attack line but
I think that what is going on there is
the conservative party obviously
realized that that is a weakness
potentially with voters for kirstarma
this is the guy that wanted a second
referendum this is the guy uh that
wanted Jeremy corbyn to be prime
minister when lots and lots of Voters
did not so I think it's in a reasonable
attack line
um for Rishi suno I think the bigger
issue for him is that he has a massive
policy problem on small boats it was
exacerbated potentially by uh the
remarks Liz trust said about President
macron while she was prime minister as a
friend or Faye well we'll see that's not
helpful if you're if you're trying to do
a d feel and I think there's other
issues going on with Rishi sunak at the
moment there's two things I would point
out one uh he's u-turned again today so
he says he's not going to cop
this is the um the climate change
conference uh in Egypt he says he's not
going because of domestic policies that
is quite controversial Boris Johnson
then confirms last night in an interview
in Sky News that he is going and this
morning uh Rishi sunak is going so again
you get this feeling of sorry this is
meant to be about stability these are
u-turns I think the other thing that I
would have picked up in prime minister's
questions there was he was asked by the
Westminster leader of the SMP Ian
Blackford about the pensions triple lock
now this is a prime minister he won the
steps of number 10 and in prime
minister's questions last week said I am
sticking to 2019 Manifesto commitments
that is a conservative party
um
reason to govern or mandate not a Boris
Johnson mandate there my words not his
and it and in provinces questions
obviously the triple lock so you will
commit to lifting
um pensions by inflation if it's the
highest figure of wages two percent or
inflation and it is obviously very high
at the moment Willy commit to lifting by
inflation he would not commit again in
prime minister's questions saying it
would not be right to comment on
individual policy measures before the
Autumn statement he said I think
everyone knows we do face challenging
economic Outlook and difficult decisions
will need to be made and then he said I
would say as Chancellor my character's
Chancellor demonstrates fairness and
compassion in everything we do now maybe
that's a hint that he will but again
stick to what you said you would do if
it was a Manifesto commitment why is it
difficult and you said you're going to
stick to that why not just commit to
that now Liz trusted it two weeks ago
for the for the for the viewer for the
pensioner it might feel like a
government flip-flopping uh at a time
when what was she seen that really needs
to do is Project competence and
stability